>>Narrator: Minutes before
the daily 8:00 A.M. broadcast
at Nuuanu Elementary,
the crew is at ease.
The kindergarten weatherman
is warming up, and fifth-
and sixth-graders stand
ready at the controls.
>>Man: Make a jaw.
>>Narrator: In the next room, their
teacher, who doubles as a magician,
wrestles with The Tasmanian Devil.
>>If you're doing, let's say,
geometry and then you want
to show angles, you can
say, "Here's an acute angle.
Here's an obtuse angle.
Here's a right angle."
Things with shapes, you
can make circles, squares.
Lots of geometry involved.
>>Narrator: Suddenly, a
crisis grips the control room.
>>No, go back, Oh!
>>Narrator: The opening
tape isn't cued properly,
and the anchors are caught
off-guard, but Chun is unconcerned.
>>They're panicking.
Well, let them panic.
>>Chun: Our emphasis
is on problem-solving,
because that's the real
world, and they have to know,
if something goes wrong,
how to problem-solve.
>>Narrator: After a quick
fix, the show rolls on.
>>Get your computers ready to type
in the address for today's question.
>>Narrator: It's a daily team
effort that over the course
of the year involves all of
the school's 400 students.
>>Girl: I didn't know there are so
many ways to show respect to others.
>>Boy: Me too.
>>Chun: We have all different
grade levels participating,
from kindergarten, they're doing the
weather reports, first- and second-
and third-graders are doing book
reviews, fourth-, fifth-, sixth-,
they're doing different
kinds of projects.
So we get everybody involved.
>>Boy: Good morning Nuuanu.
My name is Matthew and I'm
a kindergartner from B2
and today's weather is windy.
>>Narrator: While most schools are
reticent to put expensive technology
in the hands of elementary children,
Chun believes it's all part
of the learning process.
>>Chun: So you can add
narration, your audio, to that.
>>Chun: You need to trust
the kids with the technology.
In the past, they said, "Well,
just let the good students
play with the computers."
Well, what about the majority
of the students, you know?
If you only let the good students
touch the technology, then the rest,
they won't learn anything.
So we have to give every
child from K through 6
in our school an opportunity
to work with the technology,
to use it as a tool to
support their learning.
>>I'm writing a script for broadcast.
>>For tomorrow?
>>Oh, no. In four weeks, but
then I'm getting a head start.
>>Woman: Okay, so, boys and
girls, right now what we're going
to do is we're going to
log on to the Internet.
>>Narrator: Introducing students to
technology begins in the first grade.
Erin Okita's class raised money
to adopt an endangered sea turtle
through a Caribbean
conservation group.
They can track the turtle on the Web.
>>Erin: So, boys and girls,
where is Miss Junie to right now?
>>Costa Rica.
>>Erin: Costa Rica, Good.
>>Erin: A lot of them, they
haven't been on the Internet before,
and so I thought it was
a great way to introduce
that kind of technology to them.
What I wanted them to do is actually
start early having experience using
the resources that they
have available to them.
>>Is it the same land area?
Is it the same shape?
>>Erin: Well, the main concept
of this lesson, I guess,
was to connect themselves
with the rest of the world,
and so I wanted them to feel
that they're a part of something,
you know, other than just
something here in Hawaii.
>>Where is it that you are
going to place it inside
of your HyperStudio card stack?
>>Narrator: In a fourth-grade
project, students use technology
to connect with their ancestors.
>>Okay, and great-great grandma;
who is great-great grandma?
>>Pearl Onaka.
>>Narrator: Each student
created a multimedia version
of their family history based on
material gathered from their elders.
>>I was about 35 years
old at this time.
I worked in a hospital.
No, no, pharmacist.
>>Oh, okay, what did you do for fun?
>>Fun, Oh, I played
baseball, played baseball.
>>Oh, okay.
>>Marjorie: Even though,
say, a student might not have
as descriptive a paragraph
on paper, they were able
to express themselves differently
because of the technology.
>>Is mom going to be able to
provide more pictures like this?
>>I have one with their grave.
>>Marjorie: They also have to create
pictures that are representative
or symbolic of their family.
It's a different way of
expressing themselves.
It gives more of them
a chance to shine.
>>Eleanor: One of the goals that
we've had at Nuuanu School is
for every child to be
an independent learner.
The teachers know that learning is
the responsibility of the child,
where they are to be their mentors
or to guide them, but otherwise,
we want them to be the
doers and the learners.
>>Child: Oh, wait,
for 2 minutes, yeah?
>>Yeah. Okay, I've got my timer on.
>>Eleanor: Because we are a small
school and we know all the children,
you are able to identify the
children, you know their needs,
you know their talents, you know
what they're capable of doing,
you know how to motivate them,
you know their learning styles,
and I think that's what
education is all about.
>>Narrator: At Nuuanu, students
learn by doing hands-on projects
like sampling the water quality of
a stream that runs past their school
and empties into Honolulu Harbor.
>>That means the water
is dirty or clean?
>>Woman: Oh, very clean, it
doesn't have any of that phosphate.
>>Narrator: It's a science project
that also provides a
valuable community service
to the Hawaii Department of Health.
>>Watson: A lot of the data they did
collect on Nuuanu Stream is important
to us because normally
Nuuanu Stream is not one
of the streams that we study.
>>Child: How many more minutes?
>>40 seconds.
>>Watson: Once they get into
the field and see us doing this
in a regular work situation,
they have a real feel of knowing
that this is not just
lessons, this is real life.
>>Narrator: Near the harbor, students
made a temporary specimen pond
and collected seaweed that was
then taken back to the school
and pressed between book pages.
The entire day was documented on
video and later edited and posted
on the school's website
so other students
and the Nuuanu community could
experience it on the Web.
>>Boy: That is some dirty water.
>>Narrator: The school site provides
a remarkable record of the learning
that goes on here, and
from the first day of class
to the culminating May Day
celebration of Hawaiian culture,
it's clear that everyone in the
community, from kindergartners
to grandparents, gets involved.
>>Eleanor: What works at
Nuuanu School is the fact
that we really think family.
We really support each other.
It's phenomenal how much the school
can do with parents supporting you,
and they support us 100 percent.
[ Singing ]
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.